welcome to this meeting of the executive
um first item on the agenda is the
attendances um I have had no apologies
for absence um received so we'll go on
to Declarations of interest of which
I've received on prior to the meeting
but anyone have a declaration of
Interest I'll take that as a note so if
we go on to item three which is the
minutes from the meeting held on both
the 18th of September and the 25th of
September I'm happy to move that these
are accurate all those in
favor thank you very much and then to
item four which is questions from the
public and I understand we have four
questions from Mr Chris boy and as Emma
with as ever with this Emma our pastor
will ask the question and then we'll go
to the relevant executive member and
officer for the response so question one
please thank you all four questions
relate to the draft Revenue budget
proposal report uh 2024 2025 and mtfs
2025 to 2027 the first question uh
refers to page 52 of that report the
third full paragraph on that page and
asks the question whether the word
underestimated should read
overestimated thank you goes to
councelor Harding thank you leader um
the use of the term is to emphasize the
importance EMP the importance of
maintaining the
reserve can hear some
else's um at a prudent level sufficient
to mitigate the risk of a shortfall in
this significant income stream in
comparison with other reserves the
estimated balance of 5.66 million
although material is considered to be
the lowest required balance given the
significance of the income derived from
business
rates thank you very much if we go to
question two then please given the
perceived current difficulties of the
government to bring down the various
measures of the rate of inflation
despite the pro projections made by the
ons please could the executive member
for finance give an opinion of the level
of confidence being placed on the
Assumption for General inflation as
applicable to 2024
2025 thank
you the assumptions underpinning the
rates of inflation in these budget
figures the general and contractual
inflation range between 3 and 7% and
reflect the range of increases dependent
on the type of contract and the agreed
contractual terms specific to each
contract some contracts contain
increased measured at CPI RPI using
specific times for example September CPI
whilst others are based on estimates of
forecast inflation the bank of England
forecast assumes their target of 2% will
be reached by late
2024 the assumptions in the draft budget
will be updated based on latest
forecasts during the preparation of the
final budget
report thank you and over to question
three tur to pay inflation given the
continuing profess pressures sorry on
public sector pay by the Awards being
made in the private sector coupled with
the reemergence of significant action by
the Union could the executive member for
finance give an opinion of the level of
confidence being placed on the
Assumption for pay inflation as
applicable to 2024
2025 thank you estimating the level of
pay inflation has been recognized as a
risk in the preparation of the draft
budget and I will refer to some of these
points as I talk about the draft budget
later on average pay Awards over the
previous two years were in the region of
6% largely reflecting the increase
increases in the National and real
living wage rates the current assumption
for
2425 is 3% and reflecting the downward
trajectory in the inflation rate the
assumptions on the pay award have also
been benchmarked against GM authorities
and are aligned with the assumptions
being made by the other districts
estimates will be updated in preparation
of the final budget report and will take
into account latest forecasts and
possible announcements released as part
of the Tim statement
thank you and to our final
question question number four given the
statement at
7.65 could the executive publish their
final budget report in a sufficiently
timely manner to allow proper scrutiny
by any residents wishing to do so indeed
plee please could they now indicate an
appropriate latest date for
publication thank you it is acknowledged
that there have been several points
raised around the timing of budget exact
and Council meetings generally those
points link to a request for more time
to consider the proposed budget ahead of
the deadline for submission of
amendments based on that feedback we
have agreed following change in the
approach to budget exac and Council we
will keep both the exac and Council
meetings scheduled for the same evening
which will be the 21st of February
2024 we will bring forward the agenda
send out for Budget related items for
the 7th or 8th of February the subtle
but important change will provide
members with additional time to consider
the proposed budget to consider an
alternative budget proposal should they
wish to an to a with the council's
section1 officer prior to the executive
and Council
meetings thank you very much thank you
Emma for asking those questions and
councelor Harding for responding that
concludes all our questions for today so
if we now move on to item five which is
matters from Council or over view in
scrutiny committee so if I go to
councelor Aton first of
all thank you leader um I've just got
two items and I'll be very brief um the
first one is to make sure that the
executive know that uh scrutiny has set
two dates for scrutinizing the draft
budget uh the dates are 28th and the
30th of
November uh the the other matter just
wanted to raise um it is that scrutiny
is looking into how the public uh access
our services um and and the responses
from the services um we we recently held
an informal meeting of scrutiny where
officers presented a briefing paper
regarding the present systems um on how
members of the public are responding to
when they try to connect our service
areas um as a result of that briefing uh
the members have putting together an
interim report to bring to the attention
of the executive issues that we think
that they will need to consider well
thank you for
that thank you very much councilor Aton
as ever I know that all of us in the
executive will closely through those two
scrutiny sessions that you've you put
into the uh the diary um councelor buts
oh sorry Council car you want to
comments um hi thanks for that Council
action do you know which which scrutiny
will fall on which
night yeah we we we we get a full report
on what you're going to discuss tonight
uh at scrutiny and where we we ask
questions that's the first uh evening
which is on the 28th and third 30th will
be um around the services that we we
normally
scrutinize so it's a 30 you okay thank
you thank you very much uh councelor but
do you have anything to bring to us from
the health scrutiny Committee just a
couple of quick points one is the we've
got a task and finish group that's been
looking at Social
prescribing uh and that's an only
process at the moment this is about uh
organizations that help um alleviate
issues with local residents and people
connecting with the council as well uh
and on the main scrutiny we're looking
at some of the issues that things like
just come on now is the IVF program as
it we've not have much detail on it at
the moment but there has been one of two
issues that come up people don't know
what the level of
uh let's the process and the timing
because people talk about postcard
lotteries and many other things in for
different areas so we we're trying to
look at uh how this is being looked at
in our area so uh that's just something
that's kicked off at the moment so uh
we'll be getting further information on
that as we progress thank you thank you
councel but that sounds like some very
valuable work streams there so thank you
for that okay if we move on to item six
then which is the draft Revenue budget
proposals and medium-term financial
strategy uh for 25 262 627 if I go to
councelor Harding to introduce this
paper thank you leader
um I'm going to make no apologies for
taking this report really slowly and
quite detailed really because I don't
believe I would do it justice if I were
just to say the report is in front of
you and I expect you to have read the
report I think there are some very
detailed pieces of information contained
within this report that are worthy of um
analysis discussion and of course this
is the draft budget there is a period of
time now for us to look further at some
of the proposals and some of the
information contained and as councilor
Acton has referenced the budget scrutiny
will form one of those sessions where I
hope all members will be
involved I understand that some of you
may feel this report is difficult
detailed and difficult to digest it is
but it is also one of the most important
roles you have as a councelor to ensure
that the council's finances are robust
and balanced and that you ask the
appropriate questions around financial
management and
risk so can I start off by saying thank
you to all the officers involved with
this report I am sure all of us in this
room recognize just how challenging
times are for councils right now but let
us make no mistake about this the
funding crisis in local government has
been looming for years shrinking
government grants the rising cost of
living crisis inflation climbing
interest rates and energy costs all make
for The Perfect Storm we all of us only
need to look around the country at the
councils that have had to declare
section 114 notice and several of them
have been conservative run
authorities working now run by a liberal
Democrat Administration was under Tory
leadership and fell foul of seriously
risky property Investments Thor SL cuden
northamptonshire and recent Rumblings
around Nottingham this is not party
specific so I'm not playing politics on
that it affects every party but it is a
point of
inflection Council seeing Revenue
support grants decimated and being asked
to generate their own incomes has seen
some serious
failings Local Government funding was
not ring fenced in 2010 and the level of
Courts we have had to make has been eye
watering you will all have been in
receipt of casework for residents that
has seen them reaching out to us as a
council as the support networks that
existed pre austerity measures have
vanished Local Government funding has
fallen 50% in real
terms the report I present this evening
sets out our threee budget proposals the
draft proposals for
2425 and medium-term financial strategy
for
2527 the draft overall budget has seen
an increase of 8.59 million from 209 to
218 the budget gap for the three years
before applying any draft budget
proposals has an estimate of 54.9 3
million with 20 million of that relating
to
2425 and this report will set out a
series of measures to address the Gap in
2425 via a mixture of measures we'll be
looking at some additional funding
looking at planned use of reserves and
looking at new savings and some income
generation as I said earlier on these
proposals will form the basis of a wider
consultation with staff and members of
the public where
required it should be noted that if all
the budget proposals in this report are
implemented there remains a residual gap
of 29 million over the next three years
comprising of 6.41 million in
12.75 million in
2526 and
10.64%
final decisions will be taken into
consideration by the executive and a
proposed final budget will be taken to
Council on the 21st of
February it is recommended this evening
that the executive approve the
recommendation set before
them income and savings proposals are
set before the exec with further
consideration to be given by the
scrutiny committee and as I've said
scrutiny committee is a cross-party
function and I will hope that I hope
that this will allow for constructive
Challenge and debate to some of the
proposals put
forward an area that I'd like to to to
look at really is that the proposals
assume an overall increase to the level
of council tax of
4.99% in
2425 comprising a 2% increase for the
adult social care precept and
2.99% general
increase to not increase the council tax
by the level recommended in this report
would increase the overall funding Gap
by up to six million which could only
mean further reductions on Council
expenditure would be
necessary I think it's timely that I do
make reference to council tax because I
was aware that um when a press release
went out last week ahead of um after the
draft uh budget press release went out
the first thing that is honed in on is
council tax increases and I understand
that because that translates to our
residents into of
times but I would wish to refer the exec
to section 1. 3.3 of this report and
this looks at the significant reasons
for trafford's Gap gaps and shortfall in
funding and this relates to two things
really one I am sure we were all
familiar with in Trafford being seen as
an affluent borer but one that masks
considerable areas of need and hence an
unfair funding formula is applied to
traid secondly historic decisions were
made by the previous administration to
freeze council tax increases this is
hugely significant Trafford as 60 almost
60% of our budget is funded from council
tax have the previous administration not
made a policy decision to freeze the
rate of council tax for a period of five
years we would have been in receipt of
over 14 million pounds of additional
funding to support the budget
position I am sure some of the challenge
to me making this statement will be that
the government provided us with a
council tax Breeze Grant
but seeing a cut in Revenue support
grants and receiving some one-off grants
does not provide a secure and
sustainable footing for Council
budgets these factors have therefore
impacted adversely our current funding
position this is detailed in more depth
in section 3.3 of the
report Trafford receives the lowest
funding per head of population across
all greater Manchester authorities based
on our core spending power if we receive
the average funding per head as our
greater Manchester neighbors do we would
benefit from additional 35 million per
year low council tax as I've just said I
know um it's passed on to our residents
who year on year have seen changes to
their services since austerity measures
have been introduced despite the
proposal in the report to increase
council tax by
4.99% Trafford will still maintain lower
than average council tax rates and would
remain the second lowest in Greater
Manchester and the chart in the report
serves as a useful indicator as to where
Trafford sits amongst it GF
neighbors so going back to when I
referenced at the beginning your role as
a counselor in some of this I would like
to refer members back to section 1.1
that outlines our legal duties as a
council you will know in section
1.1.5 some facts laid out there from our
section 151
officer and whilst we are not in a
position where we are considering a
section4 notice it is only right and
prudent to report that risk factors are
raised over a decade of austerity Rising
demands across social care and the
continuing cost of living crisis leaves
us with minimal Financial Headroom to
absorb Financial
pressures we cannot ignore the risks of
a section 114 in the future but I want
to offer assurances that this
Administration alongside officers of
this Council are leaving no stone
unturned in considering the way we
balance our budgets and manage future
risks and I would hope that that would
be echoed by cross party um counselors
in this
chamber there is a growing demand across
children's social care which is frankly
and National Scandal councils are held
Ransom by providers charging thousands
per week to support young people an
independent review of children's social
care was launched in March 2021 and
results published in May
2022 those recommendations included an
investment of 2.6 billion over four
years in February 2023 the government
published published its own plans for
reforming children's social care which
included 200 million over the next two
years this Falls massively short of what
is required to address the challenges
facing our young people and the
workforce across children's social care
we need to be adequately funding the
preventative Services and the words that
spring to mind to me are sure start
centers our current financial position
is further outlined in sections 1.2
Trafford is not exempt from from the
financial distress being faced by
councils across the
country overspends are predicted in year
and whilst we have controls in place to
manage those over spends the position
going forward is not
sustainable if you look at sections
1.2.3 and
1.2.4 there is specific mentions made to
council reserves which I know the
question is asked every year with budget
about
reserves um business rate risk Reserve
investment strategy Reserve these
reserves reflect the Reliance we have on
those volatile income
sources the general risk
Reserve with an unallocated amount of 10
million Council reserves are at an
extremely low level with limited
flexibility to support the budget
position it is therefore vital that we
consider our in-year
expenditure
controls and the section 151 officer has
made recommendations that the use of
reserves must not exceed 30% of the
available balance the reality is there
for us all to see we cannot address the
remaining budget gaps of 30 million over
the next three years by transformational
savings
alone an area that we will look at in
Trafford and again I think requires
cross Party Support to assist with this
we have to continue to lobby for fairer
funding for low council tax and for the
government to step up and support low
funded councils like
Trafford as I take you through the rest
of the report I refer you to sections
2.1.10 and this outlines the Ambitions
and objectives of this Council for 2425
and
Beyond we are moving towards the final
year of our corporate plan we will take
stop and a revised plan will be
developed to take us Post
2025 as the executive member for finance
and change I work really closely with
senior officers around budget proposal
and service reviews all members of the
exec are looking at areas of innovation
and creativity to address substantial
challenges and I don't know I don't want
to put anybody on the spot but some of
them might want to say a few words um
after this report is tabled around their
particular exec
areas I have referenced already that we
are one of the lowest funded um and
lowest spending councils in the country
the government's Fair funding review
appears to have been kicked into the
long grass and here in Trafford we
cannot just wait and see we have no
indication as to what the Autumn
statement may bring if
anything the impact of inflation cannot
be underestimated
I refer you to section
2.1.2 that outlines forecasts if the
economic situation continues to
worsen I do want to focus a little bit
on the lobbying that I mentioned because
I think this is a vital tool that
councils must continue to use as a way
of highlighting precarious Financial
positions and Shining a light on key
areas of
challenge I have been working alongside
other councils and counselors with an
organization called seiga some of you
will be familiar with siga one of the
largest interest groups within the local
government Association Trafford are also
part of the F20 Group which is a
cross-party group of the lowest funded
councils across the
country we are calling on the department
for leveling up housing and communities
to inject extra money into the lowest
funded
authorities lobbying is and will remain
a key strand of how we work to manage
budget pressures in the coming coming
months and
years page 24 of the report outlines the
budget funding by source and the spend
by directorate section 3.2 outlines how
we have delivered savings since 2010 but
let it sink
in that there has been a 15 billion real
terms reduction to core Government
funding between 2010 and 20
2020 as referenced earlier as well as
significant funding reductions we have
had to deal with increased demand for
adults and children's social care this
demand isn't likely to decrease but we
are now looking at how we will manage
this for the future inflationary
pressures on goods and services and the
national living wage all continue to
place ongoing
pressure I do want to make reference
here to the loss of the Manchester
Airport dividend because again that's
asked in um several sessions as to when
that money is likely to be heading back
our way although the airport is making a
strong recovery we're not expecting any
dividend payment for some time and this
actually equates to six million loss of
income to the council um the table on
page 27 of the report shows where
Trafford sits in relation to our funding
needs and what we actually
receive the ifs published a report that
outlined the varying funding needs due
to differing socioeconomic
characteristics there can be no doubt
that Trafford is a low resourced
Authority by some margin we have been
prudent and provided effective and
robust financial management of our
resources the government now needs to
help and step up and ensure that we are
fairly
funded the key areas of consideration
for our future
budgets children's placements we are
looking at a 2.9 Million overspend due
to the increased in number and
complexity of placements we have home to
school transport pressures of 1 million
we have adult placements we have
inflation as a risk the cost of the 2324
pay award is expected to cost 700k above
budget and we will use our inflation
risk Reserve to support these
pressures the over spend on the
dedicated schools grant for 2324 is
forecast to be 5.25 million this area
and the High needs block are an area of
concern for councils across the country
and I'll look I'll speak a little bit
more about that later on so how are we
planning to manage the
overspend and it is critical that we do
this I referenced earlier that continued
use of ear marked reserves affects our
ability to prepare a robust medium-term
financial
plan page 30 and 31 of the report
outlines in more detail the ways we are
looking to mitigate overspend
I would draw members attention to
section four of the report which looks
at potential future funding and reviews
there have been broad statements of
intent but there's not sufficient detail
for us to make confident predictions
about funding available to us the spring
statement provided no new funding
announcements for local government aside
from 63 million swimming pool support
fund which I do know the council has put
a bid in for some of that the ifs
analysis suggests realterm funding
reductions over the next three years
which implies a continuation of
austerity
measures Local Government funding
reforms are not looking likely to happen
in the near future and the business rat
retention review will not take place
until at least
2526 section
4.2.8 outlines information on the
trailblaze the Devolution deal and
investment zones those authorities in
the designated investment zones can
retain 100% business rate growth for a
period of 25 years and all of GM will
benefit from the 10-year Trailblazer
deal but I have to say these are
incredibly complex areas that we much
more information is needed before we
know what this will actually mean for
Trafford so the areas of Financial Risk
and concern to the council remain around
adult social care reform those
non-recurrent fundings and pressures
will always continue to be there the
outturn reports are stated are showing
in year over spend across children
social care so that those demand-led
budgets are continuing to create
pressure and stress for us the schools
in dedicate and dedicated schools Grant
the council is working with the DFE to
develop some mitigation plans around
this the national living wage the real
living wage and fair price for care is
another area of
risk inflation escalating levels of
inflation have been well documented
whilst we have seen a drop today this is
still significantly still a
significantly higher figure than the
bank of England Target of 2% inflation
rates are set to remain high over the
coming months which is a particular
concern regarding Energy prices and
contractual inflation from companies in
our supply chain more detail on the
impact of inflation can be found in
section
4.3.9 of the
report
in summary regarding assumptions the
degree of financial uncertainty faced by
the council and the lack of clarity on
Government funding after
2425 means we have continued
difficulties when forecasting for the
future and whilst it isn't it's not
uncommon at draft budget stage to be
faced with a gap there is a level of
concern about the Gap that remains over
a decade of service courts does not
leave an awful lot of meat on the bone
for us to go out as a
Council a full and comprehensive list of
budget saving opportunities to be
developed over the coming months is
listed on page 48 of the
report the section that I know many
members have an interest in is the
council reserves as I've said and
section seven of the report lists our
current position and these are reviewed
on an annual basis to ensure they remain
appropriate in relation to new
challenges
faced the nine Reserve categories are
listed and as the 3 of March 2023 the
reserves amount stands at
99.64% for the several of the local
authorities about this issue is that
dedicated School Grant the predicted
overspend on the dedicated School Grant
is 5.3 million for
2324 and we've already brought forward a
high needs block deficit of
4.13 which when added to the current
deficit equates to
9.43
million this is a national picture that
we are seeing emerge we're seeing a huge
increase in the number of people
supported by the high needs block
through Education Health and Care
plans um it's placing an exponential
rise on the council's high needs blocks
across the
country and section 8.2.0 outlines some
of the ways we are seeking to address
this issue and improve our offer but
vitally this is about how we improve
outcomes for children and young people
we alongside other councils across the
country will continue to Lobby the
government around the national prices in
children's social
care you'll see all the savings and
proposals are listed from page 68 of the
report and I do welcome The Wider
engagement of members and scrutiny in
relation to the proposals and to
conclude if you are all still with me at
this
point we are absolutely facing one of
the most challenging times for local
government
Finance you only have to look around the
country to see that we are all facing
similar challenges and enough is enough
Trafford has played the game we have set
balanced budgets we have cut our CL the
irony that we have a government
Department that references leveling up
that funding from leveling up really is
a drop in the ocean compared with what
we have lost for austerity measures it's
also the time and energy that is spent
by offices writing bids and local
authorities pitching against each other
we are incredibly grateful for The
Parting parting to leveling up fund I
have to say but if we had a fairer and
more consistent funding offer for local
authorities such as Trafford we would
really really start the leveling up that
is much needed thank
you thank you very much Council Harding
for that comprehensive report back of
what is a very complex area of of
council business so thank you for that
um are there any questions or comments
from members of the executive councilor
Hines thank you leader um I would like
to thank gra Bentley and the team for
this set of proposals and also thank
Council Harding to taking us through the
report and for comprehensively
explaining the scale of the challenge
ahead for us um and there is no doubt um
that the financial picture is incredibly
challenging in Trafford um as Council
Harding has explained we are one of the
lowest funded local authorities in the
country um and it is as Council Hardin
has also said incredibly difficult for
all local authorities um many of whom
have actually gone under um who are very
very close to the financial Edge um but
the set of proposals we have um brought
together tonight in this budget um
proposal draft budget proposal um
contains the necessary very sensible
decisions that are required to protect
trafford's finances to protect our
Frontline services our libraries our
Parks our green spaces our children and
young people um and our vulnerable
adults um but the papers this evening
also demonstrate how we're not standing
still as a local Authority but they show
how we're being Innovative um in
bringing in that vital investment that
we do need into the Borah into our town
centers um and in my own portfolio how
we're investing millions of pounds into
our Leisure centers um we're building on
the hugely successful Redevelopment of
erston Leisure Center um as we see um
the process of redeveloping altering gum
um and our plans for um stretford as
well and as Council Harden as reference
we are grateful for the leveling up
funding um that we have for Partington
and we're excited to see um those plans
start to come together as well and all
of those things will support our health
and well-being um priorities so thank
you very much for that thank you
councelor Heins councilor
Carter um thank you leader thank you to
the finance team thank you to councelor
Harding um obviously I I have overall um
[Music]
um
children and um there obviously um
they're one of the major parts of the of
the overspend and whilst Council Harding
has already talked about the children's
placements this homeschool transport and
school
um DSG I want members to be reassured
that we're not complacent about this
overspend so when it comes to Children's
placements um EV every expensive
placement is reviewed on at least a
monthly basis so some more frequently
than that so that we understand um if if
that's the right setting for that child
um for home school transport we're
looking at all Alternatives about
whether we can pay parents differently
whether schools could do more and for
the schools
DSG um we've made a brilliant start in
traford trying to mitigate this with a
stronger offer in mainstream schools by
expanding our local provision of special
schools and specialist units and
improving our commissioning arrangements
and we're also part of the Northwest
sand change partner ship that we hope
will bring in additional funding and
resources I would also draw colleagues
attention to the error that was
calculated with the national funding
formula traffic schools are actually
getting 1.72 million less than
originally announced in August school
budget should have increased by
2.7% and this is now down to
1.9% this is an error made in
Westminster but it's traff for children
who are paying the price thank
you thank you Council C for drawing
attention to that that second point
there that is ex very disappointing to
hear that that money is not with us in
Trafford as a result of a an issue in
Westminster and also for for
demonstrating how close you are and our
officers are to the each budget line
that we have because we know that we
take our responsibilities very seriously
we look at every single line to the
letter to make sure that we're
we're delivering all the services and
looking after people at the same time
councelor
adset thank you uh leader just briefly
so much has been said already and indeed
I'd like to just add my thanks to all
the off of those involved and putting
the papers together it's very
comprehensive very detailed there's a
lot of information there it's certainly
one of the most difficult times I've
ever come across since having in the
council which is a long time now I would
just like to comment particularly on one
area and then that's actually how how
these proposals moving forward for the
provision of school cleaning and School
meals is been going to be like to be
severely affected by surging inflation
and cost of living crisis up to now
they've managed to absorb Ser the on
cost obviously that cannot carry on and
this may result in the future is having
to withdraw from providing those service
and results that might have on the
services and the staff involved in those
so it's an area of real concern on this
one and I think it's not 100% confirmed
all those yet I think as of have said
and we need we need to make further
information but is never real concern
something that I think we can hold all
share share those sort of problems
because it's um again it's the young
people who will suffer most likely on
this so thank
you thank you councilor ad said I think
that demonstrates the obviously the
financial challenges local authorities
across the country you're facing but
also other public sector services such
as our schools and and and the NHS as
well in a different matter so thank you
for for drawing that out uh councilor
Patel thank you leader um to Echo uh
thanks to officers the finance team and
councel Harding for a very detailed
report um I know that the the work on
this budget started the day after the
last one um so it's a tremendous piece
of work um I think it paints a very St
picture of local government Finance
which could be described as broken uh
headlines yesterday shocked to see David
Cameron return um but from this report
is quite clear his influence has never
left um local government Finance um
we're not just a lowf funded Authority
we're a low spending Authority uh just
7% of our spend is discretionary we
would have to cut all of that to
discretionary spend and more to even
meet the uh the budget savings we have
to make over the next three years um
within my portfolio we we work very
diligently um to find savings and um uh
income Revenue income uh we we work very
hard within the investment management
strategy which has brought Millions to
trafford's budget over the last few
years um we um apply for and Chase any
type of external funding pop we can um
Trafford will always apply for
everything that's that's going um
regionally and nationally and as others
have said we've had some success with
and grateful for the leveling up fund
but also GM Brownfield fund and shared
prosperity fund which can we can apply
to capital projects that make a real
difference um to Trafford residents but
that process is extremely time consuming
and unpredictable and what we really
need here for local government is is
fair long-term um funding that provides
us with a stable basis on which to plan
for our residents thank you thank you
councilor Patel I mean the the report
does reference that you could say local
government Finance is broken it
certainly is uh a broken model has been
for a long time now and I think you
demonstrate trafford's unique case that
we'll be U we'll be using as a lobbying
to government in in terms of the
historic council tax is is lower than
our GM neighbors but also lower than
average across the country the fact that
we are fun one of the lowest funding um
uh funded in the the country as well
indeed part of the F20 as Council
Harding referenced before and because of
that the ability to accumulate reserves
is very difficult so you find yourself
in a situation like Trafford a low spend
low counil tax local Authority where you
don't have enough in terms of reserves
to draw on and that does cause us you
know considerable pressures we're not
the only ones I know that but there is a
unique Traer story to tell and that is
something that we'll be looking to do
through our lobbying exercise as well so
thank you for for touching on that too
councilor Slater thank you leader and
I'd like to thank um rly and his team
and and Council Harden for the hard work
that they've done and getting us this
far with the budget I just wanted to say
that in Adult Services we are um 36% of
the budget of the council so we are a
massive um massive um piece of it's
massive service that we that we have to
provide to our residents and we all know
that issues that are happening in
hospital with the pressures on hospitals
that then um in goes handing glove and
causes pressures on us in Adult Services
so um I understand fully why the
2.9% adult social care preset would need
to be set so that we can actually keep
our um adults um and and those that and
we need to look after as safe as
possible in Trafford and and and I know
that we are Nathan and his team are
looking at some really um good
Innovations going forward or even
looking at um techn technological
technological solutions and we have um a
pilot that will be going live and this
month it will bring some savings and to
our services but there should be no
detriment to any of our residents so um
as long as we don't have any um
unplanned winter pressures it looks like
we may be quite safe in Adult Services
uh fingers crossed and I'd just like to
thank Nathan and the team for all the
hard work that they've been doing and
it's a never it's it's a never moving
feast in Adult Services so um you
know the money that we're getting in we
we actually need it for those for those
residents thank you leader thank you uh
councilor SL and again you you touch on
an area where decisions taken over a
decade ago have left to increased demand
pressures in our demand Le budgets and
it led to those budgets growing as a
proportion of the overall Council budget
and it's very good to see some of the
Innovative practices that Nathan and his
team are considering I on a lighter note
have seen one of the robots it did
wander past my office the other day so
if we if we look at how we can use
technology and Innovation to look at the
way that we deliver support and Care
differently I'm I'm all for that because
you know there are different ways of
doing
Council thanks chair just to supplement
a point that's been made by Council of M
about Trafford being a low spending
local Authority councelor Harding did
indicate in the report that uh The
Institute of fiscal Studies have
undertaken a really robust investigation
of local government they've looked at
150 of local authorities in England and
Wales and when you look at local
government spend per head of population
Trafford is ranked right at the bottom
of that list we are
150th 150 councilor Patel I think was
correct to describe the funding
mechanism for local government in this
country is broken it's about time that
the conservatives at Westminster
recognize the Injustice at the heart of
um the mechanism that we could have to
work to and did something to address it
thanks CH thank you again that's a very
good point despite the robust way in
which we've managed this budget over the
last five years there is a unique story
to tell with traford and the ifs study
was shocking in terms of uh what it
indicated in terms of the funding per
had for local government in Trafford
compared with other local authorities
again drawing on a point that councelor
Harding made before in terms of the core
spending power ah head um RS is
8429 versus 991 and2 p on a GM for the
GM average for the rest of the uh local
authorities of GM if we received the
same funding per head as our GM
neighbors we'd be looking at an
additional 35 million per anom that is
the Stark difference that we have with
Trafford in the way that we've been
funded over the years and these are the
decisions that we've had to take over
several years now um and that is why the
lobbying exercise that we're looking at
and telling that Trafford story is so
important in the next few weeks as we
head into the Autumn statement as we
head into the settlement and we move
close to the February buet buget
time okay well thank you everyone for
those questions are there any wider
questions so councelor Enis first
report thank you leader and thank you
councelor Hardin for the comprehensive
report great thanks as well in
particular for the time and attention
you've given the liberal Democrat group
so far in the budget process is very
much appreciated we understand how
valueable your time is as one of the
worst funded councils in the country
Trafford is extremely vulnerable as has
already been said tonight to these
Current financial pressures and and this
report makes that strikingly clear our
F20 lobbying work as a council could not
be more important and loal Democrats
have been supported of that work to the
state and we'll continue in that way I
just want to turn to social care firstly
um can I get a sense of how things are
progressing with talks across greater
Manchester on social worker pay what we
really need to put a stop to in my view
is this situation we have every year
where each Council approves Market upls
to try and recruit agency social workers
that we need essentially though we're in
a bidding war with our neighbors and
when what we really need is a joint
agreement which allows us to share uh
skills and resources across the region
without hammering our finances to the
tune of quarter of a million every year
or so now every time I ask that question
whether it's an employment committee or
elsewhere everyone sort of looks at
their shoes and I I understand that
that's how working with the great
manester Authority can make you feel
sometimes but I really hope that we are
making progress at a greater Manchester
level because that will have the
potential to make a huge difference on
the way on the social care funding
pressures that we face not withstanding
of course the fact that the government
could choose to fund the sector properly
itself although with this slot there
isn't a hope of that um I also want to
make a point on communication
specifically in relation to council tax
because people do and Council hard said
this people do feel that council tax
goes up every year while Services stand
still or even decline we all know that
the government has chronically
underfunded Trafford for years is as
Council Harding said we all know that
the previous administration of this
Council tried to stop the clocks on
council tax and let traff sink into a
funding black hole but our residents
don't always understand the intricacies
of local government Finance so what are
we doing in terms of our Communications
to make this point the council sends out
this book every year with your council
tax bill now I think this is great I you
know enjoy reading this I enjoy reading
the essay from the Leer um it's a real
page Turner um but here's the thing I'm
a local government geag I'm sorry no one
in the real world is reading this right
it's actually the message inside is
actually very important though and it's
about how we tell the story in gr
section one of the report this evening
in P Council I'm going to turn this
around when I prepared earlier um that
this is what you get you get a visual
breakdown of how each pound in in a 100
is spent on social Care on schools on
RADS Parks all of the all of the are
that local women covers I think this is
where we need to be I think residents
want to see this it comes up on the door
uh so I'd suggest that we could we just
Gally suggest really that we could be
doing a bit better in terms of how we
communicate Travis's financial position
to our residents as Eng grossing as
Council Russ's forward is in in the
every thank you councelor and I think
that Council Harding will particularly
enjoy answering the communications bit
um but if we go through that and the uh
Social Service adult social aspect and
if Nathan needs to step in we can go to
Nathan after that I was going to say
We'll def to Nathan for his um for his
response on the greater Manchester
position with social um social workers
and social care needless to say I think
every local Authority in Greater
Manchester is facing the pressure of a
of a shortage of Workforce and the
pressures of you know pay and and social
workers Crossing B borders and
boundaries and so but get na to respond
to that um in response to your point
about Communications um we are ahead of
the curve on that one councelor Anis but
but you are absolutely right because um
local government Finance is an absolute
mindfield to understand and trying to
communicate to Residents when we all
know I'm sure we've all seen um you know
residents who will feel the council is
responsible for everything and not
really fully understanding how local
government is is financed we are looking
at the use of graphics and some videos
and some very relatable and easy to
understand Communications that tell the
story of local government finance and
tell the story of Trafford as well
really so um timely that you said that
but it is definitely something we're
looking at doing Nathan I'll hand over
to you about the oh sorry
Jill thank you for the question
councelor Anis and um it's a really
interesting question and one that we
have been working on collaboratively
from children's Social Work perspective
across GM what I can say is that the
initial Focus has been on driving down
the costs of agency Social Work spend
and I can advise um the executive and
members this evening that's on the 1 of
November we went live with with What's
called the GM pledge and that is a
pledge across all 10 local authorities
in terms of what the cap will be for
agency social workers rates it includes
detail of what information should be
included in references so that we drive
up quality The Pledge will get formally
signed on the 17th of November it is in
line or probably goes further than what
was um recommended in the review of
children's social care we very much see
this as the first step to trying to
manage the market because the ultimate
aim has to be increasing sufficiency of
permanent social work
staff thank you could I just check
councelor SL did you want to come in at
this point think Jill's really covered
Le about that it's something that has
been um had the unions involved in um
across um across GM and I know that my
union was quite vocal in making sure
that we we had you know when we set the
rates for agency alongside and permanent
social workers and I just think it's
really important that the pledge is
signed as soon as possible thanks J for
saying it's going to be on the 17th but
you know it had to we have to do
something to to stop people from and
just piggy backing and going around and
around yeah thanks
thanks thank you so if we go to
councilor
Evans thank you chair um first of all
thank you to gram and the team thank you
for the briefing Graeme very helpful uh
counc Harding best summ it was not a
summary was it great I appreciate it and
and then my comments and questions are
in the spirit of trying to tease out
what's best for us all really um and
they're in order no not priority order
just in order way to come out page 16 uh
with respect to climate change and the
Redevelopment at altering Sports Center
uh we suggest we're putting in ground
Source East pumps and no gas um is that
tried and tested given where we are we
can't afford this not to work you may
not even able to answer this today it's
not really budget related but it's in
the report I think it's quite crucial
that we're not a guinea pck for a system
and that doesn't work so that's more of
a comment H one for our section1 officer
um what are the chances of section 114
notice you're probably not a Gambling
Man is is that possible to estimate that
um page 38 the CQC inspection we're
going through there's no budget for
anything we might need to do it might be
prudent our last off inspection took us
three or four years to remedy I think
perhaps there should be some we can
always get it back but I think should
perhaps be some provision um the high
needs block page 55 um there seems to be
an overp and I understand Graeme
explained this to me it sort goes into
an over position and the DFE in we
trying to sort it with the DFE it went
up by 1.2 million and um from 4.3 to
five and a bit as you alluded to how
long did it take to get to the 4 million
is the
1.2 like an annual thing or is that out
out of the norm for for this year um and
then the potential uh page 46 we suggest
we're going to run this book potentially
run this build into four day a week I
think we my my suggestion would be and
is a suggestion we've got got s water
side could we not DeCamp people out
there whenever I come in this building
it's occupancy seems very low could we
not up its occupancy by De counting
people out and
then either off ball or or or rent out
our other areas or or even dispose of it
but um that this is our Flagship
building this is where people expect us
to be uh closing it for a day would
worry me um that's my comments on the
budget but just one for uh
the leader actually which is is bus
reform I noted a 1.5 million in the
reserves which is in the reserves I
spoke to greman about that and that's
there we're going to have to pay that at
some point that's great however I do
believe coming through gmca is the bus
franchising and I know you've not been
on the transport committees over the
past five years I just know that because
I have and the the bush franchising
potentially could run a deficit of 297
million over five years I would just ask
you to seriously look at that and not
just accept it and make sure that we are
not committing to costs that
clearly as we've alluded to we we just
don't have those fundings if that
funding is going to come from somewhere
the mayor needs to provide where it's
going to come from and it's not just
going to be divided by 10
councils that's it thank you thank you
very much so thank you for those
questions they're really welcome
questions and um I in the spirit of
everything I think there there's a lot
we can answer today but also take
forward to the the uh scrutiny groups
the sessions as well with councilor Aton
just going on the bus franchising
certainly we we have questions we ask
about we discuss it officers also
discuss it across GM as well so we will
keep an eye on that we are getting more
of a revenue from the buses than was uh
first anticipated so that's very good
news but clearly we are all minded in
terms of our own local Authority
position as well so we keep having those
regular dialogues both officer and
politician level as well but so far the
story with the bus franchising is that
more people are using the buses which is
great in terms of Revenue but also great
in terms of reducing the number of
vehicles on the road and uh and also air
quality as well um so the other ones
were ultr leure Center section 114 CQC
higher needs block and the potential
four day week here so if I go to Joe and
then she can chair
thank you leader so I'm going to defer
to Richard who will respond to aling tra
Town
yeah thank you Council Adin uh thank you
Council Evans for the question so on
altringham Leg Center no it is tried and
tested um technology has been used um
elsewhere we do think coming off gas is
the right thing to do from a carbon
neutral perspective and it's also in
line with a general government um
approach terms of the closure of
Trafford Town Hall just to note that is
a proposal that is being explored it's
not definite but we are going to do it
at this moment in time um and a range of
options we have about making sure we're
making best use of our buildings just in
terms of sale water side point out a
couple things s water side is our main
customer contact point we get more
customer footfall through S water side
OB got the library in there as well so
actually closing that from a customer
point of view would have a bigger impact
than closing top of Tel we also have a
range of other agencies who use our
office space there so particularly in
Nath and Georgia area CR the health
sector so actually the impact of of
closing that for dead could potentially
be greater because of the service
delivery that that's done there but we
are working collaborative with Partners
to ensure that we made best use of all
our gram did you want to take the 114
question
yeah really glad it was raised thank you
um I suppose section 114 is really
difficult to say I think about it a lot
I do and it it's understanding the
scenarios I think that could lead to it
I just
think as Council Harding said as an
authority resilience in terms of
reserves is LW um I think where we've
come to after 12 years of austerity and
finding savings to balance budgets I
think we're in a position now that it
does feel where do you go I
think the differences this year from my
perspective I think is that everything
in in finances gift around looking at
some of the corporate measures we've got
have G we've done them can't do them
again
um we presented with an India budget
pressure that we're fan we're trying to
manage within year because if we get to
the year end on over spend that uses
some there's a figure in the report of
levels of reserves 10 million pound of
reserves that would be available to
support our budget
planning can't afford to use them all up
at once if you do what happens in 245 if
you're faced partway through the year
with growing cost pressures across the
budget so I just think it's the pro iib
but there's a lot of strands that we
want to watch I think what's coming up
we've got the national budget next week
we've got the finance settlement for
local government in
December
um but I think
114 there's not a talk about issuing a
114 I think it's just
that real shared ownership of the risk
of 114 I think is really positive from
my point I feel that from this second
meeting tonight about everyone was
trying to steer away from that we always
have done and I think as an authority we
we have Brazilian reviews independent
resilience reviews we had the LGA came
in two years ago we're doing things
right we've had a recent review
um not from the LGA this time got a
separate review that said we're doing
things but that resilience is really
well
um and I just think I suppose at this
point just have to watch really closely
as to where that position is moving
to
um so it's just ultimately the risk has
increased but I think it's for us to
stay and I think looking at in your
budgets the authorities that fail and
fail quickly are those authorities who
have had big uses of reserves to balance
budget we have done over the last few
years around Co but I think that was
exceptional
that use has come down um but we've
managed our budgets within the budget
that we set in February we've done that
each and every year and we've delivered
the Savings Program so I think track
record wise is strong and it's that that
hopefully will lead us to stay around
this problem but among a number of other
things as
well thanks gra and then the the
question was about CQC wasn't it and
some
um Nathan do you want to take
that yeah happy to take the question on
CPC um so as the report alludes um we
have um received some support from the
LJ through a peer challenge about social
care and that the report has just been
received in draft form and indeed we are
coming to have scrutiny in January to
talk about through and provide that
visibility um we actually received a
relatively mod gr um of around 25,000
which actually paid for that um which
was um specifically weed for um
preparation for CDC Assurance obviously
we have to learning from our colleagues
and children's and indeed my own
Services um which are registered with
CQC and um are subject to regular
inspection so though social care has not
been inspected for well over a decade we
do have some experience of inspection
um in terms of the preparation the the
LJ um work involved significant um
evidence packs to be produced and also
to um draft the self assessment and be
aware of where we have areas for
development um and the focus will be on
those areas of development in L of not
knowing exactly when we will be
inspected um five pilot sites have
received their draft um scores from
CQC um but that hasn't been published so
we haven't seen the published reports
yet though there are some early signs of
the kind of areas that secable to focus
on and clearly they're the areas from a
traffic perspective that we will give a
great degree of focus to ensure we can
achieve can I just come in on the
question um and I hope it's helpful to
yourself councelor ran
one of the things that has been a clear
learning point for us from a children's
services perspective is the best
preparation for any inspection activity
is to do the right things for the
service users and actually if you're
doing the right thing for the service
users inspection takes care of itself so
as um Nathan has already
articulated actually understanding the
quality of services being cited on what
performance looks like on the ground and
what difference we're making to our
residents whether they're children older
people or in a family context is the
best preparation so I think from that
point of view things like having the
lgap review understanding what the
quality of services looks like is really
strong preparation to help void being
recited on where there needs to be
Improvement okay and I think there's one
was one more on the high needs blog did
so I think the question was about how
long it's taken to get to that position
and what I would want all um members to
to really have some reassurance about is
that this is the first year that we've
had to do a high needs deficit recovery
plan so what that means in reality is
that historically our management of the
high needs block has been really robust
really strong we're in this position
because as councelor Harding reference
we've seen an increase in the number of
children needing to have an ehcp needing
to have that formal support the process
of having um a high needs deficit
recovery plan is overseen by Central
governments and the robustness of our
strategies and our approaches tested out
so it has taken a long time to get to
this point we comparatively compared to
both some of our local neighbors and our
statistical Neighbors on in such an
adverse position having said that it
does not mean that we're complacent and
the high needs deficit recovery plan is
something that's scrutinized internally
and through things like all
Forum thank you if I go now to councilor
Welton thank you leader um and like the
other members of the other parties I
would like to say thank you to councelor
Harding for that uh excellent summary of
of the budget report also gram um
Bentley um who engaged with me this
afternoon um it was very very helpful uh
and all the work that's gone gone into
this report um I think as as councilor D
pointed out to me at the start of the
meeting is summed up and by the graphic
on page 23 which shows the last three
years we've been you know using an
exceptional amount of our reserves um
and clearly that's not sustainable in
the in the longterm obiously we have
been in Co you know in covid and coming
out of covid during that um but you know
if you carry on that way in with that
kind of EX exceptional dipping into the
reserves we you know it's a sign that
the wheels are perhaps coming off not
through any fault necessarily of our own
but because of the local G Government
funding settlement and we're going you
know I can understand there's talk of
cuts and we're also going to have to
look at raising more Revenue ourselves
where possible um so I've just got to
you there's been a lot of talk already a
lot of you know comments that the green
group would agree with I'm sure um so
I've just got a couple more questions
one General and one very specific um
looking at
5.2.5 it says the aim of balancing the
cost of delivering Council services to
remove subsidy where this exists so
that's an aim we're looking to remove
subsidies where they exist um I was just
wondering if we if there are any
examples um of where subsidies exist and
where they're being considered for
removal um the other aspect the other
thing is just a very specific one the
review of regent Road car park is
mentioned um and we're just wondering
what's being reviewed with regards to
Regent Road par up obviously as Bo
counselors on al' be very interested to
know that and when's it
opening um that was
3.5.2 the Region Road um yes that's
thank you thank you councel welon
councel
Harding thank you um gra I'm going to
refer you to the subsidy and then I'm
gonna ask Richard about the carow park
thank
you I think just in terms of some of the
services we've got I think we just keep
an eye
on um in the main what our traded
services in terms of cost recovery we've
already heard tonight from Council B
said around the difficulties we got
around that particularly where that
Services is is exposed to high rates of
cost increase because of
inflation um there are other areas
across the council Services I think we
do receive Subic sell water side our
centers one which which will be looking
at as well so that's just that's just an
in couple of areas but traded Services
obviously the rafter services in there
it's just making sure that um a subsidy
is minimized
in terms of regent Road what's been
reviewed is essentially how quickly we
can get it uh open because the issue is
also are losing income there the longer
remains Clos went to be completed and
also the impact on the T Center which we
are aware of as well unfortunately as we
sit today I can't give you a Target dat
of when we expect it to open just so
there are gen and extended discussions
with the developer in order to try and
get it opened as quickly as we possibly
can and we will keep W members updated
as we are able to do so thank you I'm
going to take one more question before
we move on and it is going to be Council
FR thank you leader obviously I want to
Echo everyone's thanks this is not an
easy job is it as we heard just now the
meeting the Gap section of the report
gross budget gaps about 55 mil over 3
years Council Patel just said um
discretionary spends only about 7%
Graham tells me the other week broad
Strokes about 20 million so if we cut
everything we're still struggling in the
finance director's view written into the
report it's just not possible to bridge
this budget Gap by savings alone so we
need to lobby for fairer funding for low
low Council budgets like ourselves but I
feel we've been here before we're
talking about lobbying the government
working with the F20 group asking our
conser Council to speak to gr Grady
writing to part leveling up but each
year it feels like we just have to sort
of accept our fate and then we keep
making more and more difficult decisions
as a council we haven't found that
tactic that works to get government to
act on trafford's unique case so I just
thought perhaps we could explore a bit
about how we could get creative with our
lobbying or raising the profile we
councelor Harding just said no stone
unturned I heard um I don't know if you
can tell me how or if we're going to do
any different lobbying this year what
that really involves thank you thank you
Council Council Harding um what I would
say councilor PR is that we're not alone
um I think there are many other local
authorities across the country who share
exactly the views that you have just
expressed we are not
alone but it is strength in numbers it's
strength in unity and that's why um you
know siga have done a draft Manifesto of
what they think those um what what their
asks are key asks from government um
they've broken it down into things like
business rates children social care
adult social care some of those areas
where they really think the government
should hone in and focus on what local
government needs to make things
better working with Graham and the team
it's something that is going to be alive
and ongoing piece of work um where
opportunities arise we will make sure we
partner with other local authorities um
I have met with the finance leads across
great to Manchester the stories are all
the same um you know we are looking at
every given opportunity to raise the
voice and the profile of Trafford and
I'm sure that some of our conservative
members here share those views that's
what I've he this evening and what what
opportunities you have available to you
we are happy to have those conversations
too as well as scrutiny so I hear what
you're saying councilor FR I share those
views we're not alone it's an ongoing
piece of work banging that drum and bang
that drum we will continue you to do
thank you and just to add I mean it's a
very very good point that you make
councelor for I mean the way that we
communicate and Lobby is incredibly
important now um with the uh the size of
the non-discretionary Spenders it is and
the the scope that we have to to act um
we have been looking at some bespoke
work um and looking at telling a a
Trafford story and I alluded to that
earlier in this uh in in this item and
that is something that we'd really like
to draw out quite quite strongly this
time the I say that that perfect storm
that we have here of being low council
tax low funded low reserves was a stark
story for us to tell and we're looking
at the best way that we get that story
out there and that will involve getting
in touch with d but also telling that
story to our residents and as uh
councilor Harding says that that close
work that we do with the F20 Group which
is cross party and siga as well the two
organizations that we work together with
and and and do some things during the
year um to to argue the strong case
where those in the local authorities
that are the lowest funded should get
special attention because we're the ones
that we are coming up with some very
tough uh Financial circumstances even
compared with others that are going
through a difficult time at the moment
but yeah it's a very important thing for
us to look at and getting our coms and
lobbying right this year conscious of
time I know there are other questions
but we have got some budget scrutiny
sessions to um to to go through so I'd
encourage all members to to participate
or if you have any separate suggestions
or feedback I know that GR I know that
Council Harding would be very happy to
uh to hear from you as well um as ever
budgets are a balancing act it's getting
that balance right between the revenue
um how we use reserves how we look at
income and savings um proposals as well
we will maintain that we've got work to
do we've got a we've still got a gap at
this stage which we'll continue working
on in the background to get us to
balance position in February but what I
don't want us to lose sight on is that
we are looking to deliver a Revenue
budget of 218 million next year which
equates to a lot of services that our
local residents both both value and uh
and and actually need so we've got to
remain focused very difficult uh uh
budget for us to bridge we will do that
because we do every single year we will
take those decisions that we need to to
get to balance but we're also conscious
as a council that all our officers from
our fantastic Finance team of uh led by
Graham through to our corporate
leadership team and all staff are
delivering excellent Services day in day
out and that is what we're here to do so
the recommendations are set out in the
report as 8 to8 all those in
favor thank you so we'll move on to the
next item which is the Hackney carriage
and private hire licensing policy 2023
to 2028 now pass over to councelor
Thompson thank you
leader in July 2020 the department for
transport published its statutory taxi
and private high vehicle licensing
standards with the recommendation that
all licensing authorities bring together
all their procedures in one policy
document and make them publicly
available thus we have this policy
before us today in preparing the draft
policy officers have brought in the M
greater Manchester minimum licensing
standards that we had adopted in 2021
along with seven other greater
Manchester authorities and the purpose
of the minimum licensing standard cease
to harmonize our standards across
greater
Manchester the policy covers Vehicles
drivers operators standards and the
overriding objective is to improve the
safety of the public in particular
children and vulnerable adults but also
to support the the objectives of our
clean air plan the history of Licensing
standards across greater Manchester in
the last 5 years has been quite complex
in 2021 the council approved stage one
and stage two recommendations of the
greater Manchester minimum licensing
standards however these have not been
fully implemented to date largely due to
the delay in the Clean Air plan which
has resulted in a delay to the clean
taxi funds on which much of the policy
decisions
rely also adding to the challenges in
developing this policy has been the
pandemic and the resulting supply chain
con constructions of vehicles and paths
the cost of living crisis and inflation
and the consultation in August we had
with our drivers and operators also
informed this draft
policy
therefore there are amendments to the
minimum license standards are included
in this proposed policy namely there a
more details in the policy around these
amendments but I'll just do the
headlines namely signage for private
higher Vehicles maximum time
restrictions for drivers to notify the
council convictions arrest or summons
the maximum time time allowed outside of
the country before a license needs to be
a license needs to be renewed and
Council approval for any advertising
displayed on any
taxes and also the vehicle age of coming
onto Fleet in recognition of the
enormous financial burden of drivers and
license lies in replacing their vehicles
the restrictions on vehicles being under
five years old for private higher
vehicles and seven years old forne
carriages have been removed however all
importantly our vehicles will still have
to conform to the emission
standards around the emission standards
in March this year the council agreed to
extend the implementation date for the
existing Fleet to the 1st of April
2026 with the caveat that should there
be more delays to the Clean Air plan and
funding support for taxes the director
of place could extend this to April
2027 however there are ongoing
discussions between the transport for
greater Manchester and the government
and all 10 greater Manchester
authorities are been asked to agree an
emission standard and consider the
possibility of starting this sooner than
2026 with this in mind it is proposed
that we amend the current delegation to
allow the director of place and the EXA
member to bring forward the
implementation date of the emission
standards should this be appropriate so
in summary to comply with the government
recommendations we we have we have
produced a comprehensive license policy
to publ publicly we've introduced the
greater Manchester minimum license
standard standards within the policy
with some amendments to those standards
and we have amended some time
restrictions and signage policies to due
to the feedback we've had from drivers
during the consultation period and we
are proposing that the direct place an
exit member be delegated the power power
to bring the
emissions uh standards forwards if
deemed appro
appropriate I want to thank all the
offices in producing this document and I
hope you can support this draft policy
thank you thank you very much Council
Thompson for that excellent summary
there um any questions or comments from
the executive Council
Hines thank you leader and thank you
count coun
Thompson um I just wanted to um speak in
support really of the minimum licensing
standards and it's the
standardization across GM that I'm
supporting really from a safeguarding
and safety perspective um I am a a taxi
user I use a lot of taxes um because of
my um disability and and because um you
know I have a vulnerability really um
and I think a lot lot of Taxi users um
are very vulnerable um do have
disabilities you've got children and
young people who use taxes to get to
school um and you have older adults who
use taxes to go shopping to appointments
um and vulnerable adults as well um so I
welcome the standardization of those
minimum standards across greater
Manchester if I'm honest um I do wish
that the government would um look at a
standardized approach nationally
um but in L of that I welcome these
proposals thank
you thank you very much are there any
wider questions councelor
Evans thank you chair um I think I can't
hardly speak on behalf of the taxi
industry but I know uh within Trafford
it's barely uh possible to run uh a taxi
and make money I know our taxi drivers
are suffering so probably so welcome the
removal of the age I think that they
will welcome that following Co they
suffered terribly um I would
query and and caution against uh the
emissions standard and taking rash
decisions on that our taxi drivers are
not making money and we are going to we
we we we are going to be losing taxis
and and we need them as simple as that
and
actually understanding how they make
money and how they finance vehicles I
think has not been overly considered
across the whole of GM particularly and
and and I I get lobbied a lot from taxi
drivers um so I'll just leave that there
and just say don't rush
to in increase the the age in the
emissions they all get tested they are
all safe and I welcome what council hin
says about you know security and and
vulnerable people that that's all valid
and not relevant but it's actually how
they make a living and they have to make
a living otherwise we won't have taxes
thank you thank you Council I don't know
if Council Thompson want to come back or
Richard
or thank you councel th coun thank you
councelor Evans I I think we we
understand the premise of the the
question we are very aware of the
challenges that the taxi trade faces at
the moment so I think we definitely
won't be making any rash um decisions I
think it will be a decision that's made
in conjunction with other GM colleagues
thinking about what's the the impact on
the taxi trade and what's the best in
terms of ensuring that we get good good
taxi service across the
G thank you and councelor
fras thank you um I'll be brief as
forgive me if we can touch on this it's
relating to our minimum licensing
standards and safeguarding perspective
we probably all know I'm not on the
licensing committee there's this ongoing
issue we have with taxis operating in
Trafford Manchester LIC outside of great
Manchester BBC says unbelievably a third
of all taxis in England now registered
in wver Hampton is unbelievable um
obviously there's parliamentary
legislation it would be silly if your
taxi can't go across a council boundary
but just focusing on our minimum license
stand safeguarding this you may not
believe me it literally came up on the
doorstep this weekend and someone's you
know the concern what reassurance can we
give um how do we manage if there's
safeguarding concerns and then turns out
that taxi is not on our books we don't
have their license plate we don't know
who they are they registered 100 miles
away and we don't have any power over
them but the they're not our
responsibility but they're our problem
because of safeguarding concern or
whatever how do we how do we tackle that
is there anything about that in the in
plans there thank you before I go to
Rich to Les coun Thompson wishes to I to
I think that's a really um good con and
and clearly this has been going on for
quite a while before it was wolver
Hampton um it was Rosendale were the
ones that were were doing this so it has
been going on for the best part of a
decade it is something as part of the
Greg manag to Trailblazer Devolution
discussions we did try and address this
and and ensure that we had like
licensing within within GM but
unfortunately we couldn't get that far
with that uh the particular negotiation
book hopefully future iterations of that
we can get to a good place with that
book Richard I don't know if you want to
add anything
I think you've mostly covered it lead I
think we all share concerns about taxes
that are licensed outside of GM
operating within um GM and other GM
mayor has come out quite strongly uh
suggesting that residents should try and
use GM registered taxes where they're
able to do so and I do appreciate that's
actually not always that easy because
when you book a taxi you don't know
where it's been um registered but but
the point that you raised is exactly the
point about why we are pushing um to
have some restrictions uh what we would
do do if there are safeguarding issues
is tax is contact the LI the appropriate
licensing Authority for that that taxing
but that is as far as we can go we don't
have control over what action that
licensing Authority can take clearly if
it's a Trafford registered taxi then it
will be reported through to our
licensing committee and it would be
members in Trafford will be able to make
that
decision thank you um I see no other
questions so are we happy to agree
recommendations one to three as set out
in the
report wonderful thank you very much um
item eight is urgent business of which I
have none but I just want to check Alex
is this your last executive meeting with
us my last all seconds last I might be
coming along on the 27th just to provide
some support right to speak until then
and we just wanted to check given we've
got a Bonus ex EXA meeting so brilliant
well on that note we will see Alex next
time and I'll see you all next time so
thank you very much and have a good
evening